l'instant puisque ont été aux états unis
si la rumeur de la semaine c'est
jennifer aniston et brad pitt regardez
là une de corzo voilà ils sont là hier
donc ils ont été vus ensemble à paris le
14 février ils ont dit dans un hôtel
parisien extrêmement connue alors est ce
que tout ça c'est un hasard ou pas elle
je vous rappelle qu'elle est célibataire
lui dans un divorce un peu compliqué est
ce qu'ils se sont remis ensemble oui ou
non flanc alors déjà il faut replacer le
contexte de cette de cette information
le rivage à savoir que jennifer aniston
tourner un film à paris depuis un moment
lui il adore paris on le sait il adore
la france il est venu à dire pour un
rendez vous culturel il ya des photos
qui existent avec lui avec roselyne
bachelot ceinturait landreau voilà mais
c'est vrai qu'ils se sont retrouvés le
14 février une date symbolique ouais
peut le dire à l'hôtel costes rue
saint-honoré qui est un très bel hôtel
mais aussi un beau restaurant café et
c'est elle qui a la particularité
d'avoir des petits salons donc on est un
peu du sort d'alcôve qu'on peut qu'on
peut privatiser si on est sûr on a les
moyens et sur les un peu célèbre aussi
et c'est là qu'ils se sont retrouvés
c'est là qu'ils ont passé un très bon
moment tous les deux après il faut dire
la vérité mathieu je sais que en
préparant cette semaine j'ai pensé à
vous parce que je sais que c'est l'un de
vos rêves qui se remettent ensemble que
c'est l'un des couples les plus glamour
avec moi plutôt québec
c'est vrai que ça fait partie des sagas
comme ducom comme jennifer lopez ben
affleck voilà les plus belles sagas
amoureuse hollywoodienne ça en fait
partie sont séparés en 2005 et depuis il
n'y a pratiquement pas eu une année où
elle a pas eu les rumeurs à venir
mettant ensemble là pour être honnête
faut aussi rappeler que c'était
l'anniversaire de jennifer aniston
quelques jours avant le 11 février donc
peut-être qu'ils ont soufflé quelques
bougies encens des proches qu'ils ont
toujours été très proches elle a
toujours invité à des anniversaires à
des des fêtes de noël etc on l'a aperçu
parfois sur des postes instagram on
n'était pas sûr que ce soit lui et puis
finalement si et c'est là je ne peux pas
vous dire en exclu mondiale ils sont en
couple ils sont ensemble mais en tout
cas ils s'entendent très bien et c'est
pas le genre de rendez-vous anodin parce
qu'ils auraient pu se cacher aussi ils
auraient est-ce qu'ils sont pas en train
d'essayer de faire du buzz doute se
moquer de vous parce que dîné ensemble
un 14 février il doutait bien que à
paris rennes et paparazzi parlerait
peut-être qu'ils se moquent de nous mais
peut-être aussi que vu que l on sait
qu'elle est célibataire
lui on sait qu'il est en procès avec
angelina jolie dans des situations
nous les lecteurs l'ailé les fans et les
journalistes il ya peut-être aussi le
public ceux qui les aiment ceux qui les
suivent peut-être qu'ils veulent faire
passer un message c'est quelque chose de
ces un coup qu'a toujours eue cac a
toujours suscité beaucoup de sympathie
que les gens toujours toujours et un
petit détail technique presse people
c'est très rare qu'on fasse des
américains ont une on peut faire céline
dion qui est pas une américaine en tout
cas qu'est pas française mais en une de
closer et d'autres journaux people
trouvé deux américains c'est vraiment
ouais on est sur du lourd donc là voilà
est-ce que les américains dans
l'émission de 1 2 laurent ruquier cette
semaine des américains dans l'émission
de laurent ruquier en direct voilà donc
notre direct non franchement je sais pas
comment ils leur posera les questions
parce qu'il a un anglais assez compliqué
quand tu regarde l'émission du coup
c'est vrai comme souvent sur le théâtre
sur tout ce qui se passe en france soit
c'est un artiste français nous hier soir
hier soir presque jamais non vous
n'allez petit coulisses des infos sur
les coûts et sur ce même les français
ceux qui font chier en coulisses enfin
ce qui sera un peu compliqué est ce
qu'un jour je le ferai ouais un jour je
le ferai mais pas aujourd'hui mais pas
aujourd'hui non un parti non à non battu
me prend de court et je vais le
regretter si
tu n'es rien tu es viré mais non
sinon on donne pas de taille à ne pas de
détails justin compliqué hein compliqué
non merci tout le monde s'excite un peu
je le fasse
[Applaudissements]
thierry
non non non parce que là ça fait mal
hein je fais mal en a mais je précise ce
que je vais dire là déjà il n'y a pas de
truc de fou et c'est pas laurent qui me
l'a dit non c'est plein de gens qui
travaillent dans l'émission c'est pas
moi c'est sûr on m'a dit que voilà
l'artiste qui était le plus compliqué je
post émission c'était camille lellouche
qui était à qui avait nui à la 6e pris
le melon techniquement ça je vis
chansons piano chez vous voilà c'est ça
c'est ce que les gens disent dans les
coulisses toujours toutes proportions
gardées on n'a pas de preuve c'est un
avis personnel de certaines personnes
c'est pas un fait établi en tout cas
j'ai souvent entendu ça à l'oreillette
j'entends c'est une âme et de serre il
m'a nous on adore ça s'est passé
et on vient le coup de colère de cyril
je me désolidarise cette info il faut
qu'un pion saute comme prévu ministre ce
sera vous
les mains qui se lèvent si c'est pour
dire du mal d'elle vous pouvez les
ranger dans votre dos un jamais de la
vie ouais c'est pour recentrer le truc à
part de ce mois ci voulait animer
l'émission vous n'hésitez pas non non
pas du tout c'est juste qu'à l'époque
moi je pense qu'elle a un peu en train
de tenir sa petite vengeance ce soir que
brad pitt quand il s'est séparé d'elle
c'est parce qu'il l'a trompée avec avec
angelina jolie
et à l'époque jennifer aniston au moment
où y tourner ce film avait contacté une
voyante hyper s'élève quelques contacts
et souvent et cette voyante lui avais
dit fais gaffe angelina jolie est un
ange noir elles ne l'avaient pas crue et
avait même dit angelina en tout cas je
te souhaite de prendre plein de plaisir
avec mon mari son tournage et bim et sa
version priant vérité avait promis à
dire que je l'avais senti senti comme
laetitia j'essaie des gens que je sens
ou pas là n'est pas ce qu'il a vu alors
c'est juste qu'ils allaient revoir parce
qu'ils sont beaux ils avaient lu un
texte du premier confinement avec un
casting d'acteurs sean penn morgan
freeman voilà pour les levées de fonds
contre le coc vide j'ai passé argent
voilà on a la vidéo on a la vidéo
regardée par l'ensemble
âgé
de
60 ans le gabbana de leur entier bah
ouais ouais ouais et le miroir le tient
le vôtre palois non j'ai pas d'émission
13e mois vous 50
cinq ans parce que pas dire son âge
c'est parce qu'il veut bon 56 56 affaire
est bien beau gosse aussi oui merci
mathieu mon âge ou non pas du tout je
voudrais maintenant votre âge radars
mais bien sûr en fait je voulais juste
deborah parler de leur relation à
l'époque quand il l'avait trompée faut
aussi préciser que c'est très très rare
que des couples aussi célèbre quand ils
se séparent restons si bons termes on
peut parler johnny depp amber brad pitt
angelina et ils sont toujours toujours
resté en bons termes et c'est ce qui à
mon avis moi je prends les paris je
pense qu'on peut mettre une petite pièce
sur le potez que leur couple se refasse
on peut prendre en exemple je vous
citais tout à l'heure jennifer lopez et
ben affleck je pense que la prochaine
saga ah oui amoureuse ouais c'est vrai
que c'est génial et je mets mes petites
pièces je me mouille la semaine
prochaine fois vous ferez un gros gros
dossier on aura 2 3 paparazzi qui seront
en plateau ici oui en train de faire
venir ne raconterons tout tout tout sur
les deux sujets te de souder des
paparazzis vous allez voir que c'est
assez passionnant comme une question
d'ordre nages parce que je pense qu'on
va partir en pub mais vas-y je voulais
juste simplement dire on va peut-être
tous un peu oublié comme quoi il ya eu
aussi des petites fioles de
spermatozoïdes via par brad pitt et
qu'elle tient peut-être temps d'haleine
par le tient un petit peu donc quelque
part mon avis ils ont dû ce 14 février
négocier ils ont buté oui
ce ne sont pas des châteaux 4